let's notice Pedro okay
hey Terry you want to know why we're
here
bye-bye no there's not a fight yet Tara
we got a call that somebody an employee
here was turning tricks up on the roof
no way yeah yes well their way that no
not cool well you know anything about
their you know anything about it no I'm
afraid of roofs ofme I'm allergic to
your loo your liver to room Melissa Ruth
that's my doctor how does that manifest
itself
how are you allergic to roofs if I look
at that I throw up you know what I'm
allergic to lies you know we had a
description about the gentleman of your
height your stature with a little hat
what at that moment the person's name
well I'll get you Brian with Mary or
Harry my name is Amir you're Harry my
name is well hold on Jerry well I saw
something one second right but listen
you know what you're misunderstood okay
I told you under you're misunderstood
and I wanted to know what if you and I
were to go up on the roof
how much would you would you I mean how
much would it be
so sorry I'm a cop
well I'm holding your hand and I'm just
asked about him you know how much
putting a doing tacos tacos tacos tacos
itself serve tonight ladies and
gentlemen hey call the police I'm being
arrested by the police
[Music]